When I was twelve years old,...
...someone put my first bat in my hand.
That sealed my fate.
Bats are the most unfairly treated animals on Earth.
Fear, not knowing what treasure they have in their local cave,...
...drives people to dynamite it, to gas them, to all kinds of things.
But bats provide us with many ecosystem services, agricultural pest control.
Each million bats destroy ten tons of insects every night.
If we lose those bats, we would lose the crops in a few months.
They're also promoting the regeneration of the forest...
...by dispersing the seeds over vast, vast areas,...
...and they pollinate...
...a lot of ecologically or economically important species of plants...
...like the agaves that are the source for tequila,...
...which represents for Mexico about three billion dollars a year.
We created a humongous network...
...of privately owned protected areas around the country...
...that today includes about 17% of Mexico's territory.
When I have a bat in my hand and I show it to anybody,...
...you see the change in a flash.
This is exactly what has been driving me for a long, long time.
I am here, at 64, continue to be the same child...
...who had his first bat in his hand.
I will never give up.